- (producer) All right, what
are we going to call you?
- Michael
- (producer) Michael? All right Michael.
Michael, where'd you grow
up? Where are you from?
- Los Angeles, California.
- (producer) Which part of
the valley? South Central?
- South Central.
- (producer) Okay. And now
tell me about your family,
you both your parents growing up?
- Yeah, my mom passed
when I was about five.
My dad passed and I was
like 20 something and
my grandma raised me up like all my life.
- (producer) How'd you lose your mom?
- She died of cancer.
- (producer) Oh, I'm sorry.
So you were raised by your
grandmother and your dad?
- Yeah, my grandmother.
- (producer) Grandmother? Where's dad?
- He was a professional
boxer. So he was there.
He was, he was there with,
you know what I mean?
He got older and passed off
- (producer) How was your childhood?
- It was like, it was kind of rough.
It was kind of rough growing up
- (producer) What kind
of stuff? Any abuse?
- Like just man, just
growing up rough, like man,
like all type of stuff.
- (producer) What's the
kind, the worst thing you
had to go through as a kid?
- Like running away from
home, getting whooped and shit
You know,
this is, dang,
getting hit
with switches and extension
cords and stuff like that.
- (producer) From your Grandmother?
- My mom and shit, I don't know.
When I got older my grandmother says the
whole house was like just
all drug addicts and stuff like that.
- (producer) What was
your, what age were you
when you left home?
- Hmm?
- (producer) What age were
you when you left home?
- I was running away at, at 11.
- (producer) Oh really?
- Yeah.
- (producer) And what are you doing on the
streets at 11 for money?
- Shit,
picking up cans and stuff or selling a
bike or something. Something like that.
- (producer) Yeah. And today you're,
you're supporting yourself how?
- Shit, selling dope
- (producer) Selling
dope. What, what drugs are
you selling mostly?
- (Michael) Crystal, weed, whatever
- (producer) And you're
selling here on skid row?
- (Michael) Yep. Yeah, I sat
around here just to survive.
- (producer) Have you done
any prison time for that?
- (Michael )Yeah I have done prison time.
2 and a half to 16 once.
I have prison time behind it.
- (producer) How old are you?
- (Michael) I'm 38.
- (producer) 38?
- (Michael) Yeah.
- (producer) Do you have kids of your own?
- (Michael)Yeah, I have a daughter.
I have a daughter who's 21.
- (producer) Did you raise her?
- (Michael) No, not really 'cause I was
out here in the streets
selling drugs and out here
living in the streets and stuff
- (producer) So you use
as well? Or used to?
- (Michael) I used to, not
anymore. I used to though.
- (producer) And you're, you're clean now?
- (Michael) Yeah.
- (producer) And who you're selling to?
Most of the people that
you see here on skid row?
- (Michael) Yeah, every day people,
people that's around here.
- (producer) Yeah, you have regulators?
- (Michael) Hmm?
- (producer) You have regulars?
- (Michael) Yeah, I have regulars
Yeah, I have regulars.
- (producer) Daily? How,
how much, how much do
people spend a day typically?
- (Michael) It depends,
they probably come through
with $150.
They probably come through
$80, $40, whatever they
come with I give it to them for it.
- (producer) A day? They're spending that?
- Yeah. They come with it.
I give them some for it.
- (producer) Right.
You have to worry about
the police and getting a-
- Yeah. You always have to worry
about the police have taken chances
on going to jail or, or,
you know what I mean?
So yeah, I take, yeah, I worry about it.
- (producer) What's
your, what's your view?
I mean, you're, you're providing a service
for something that these people want.
Do you, do you see a
role in their addiction?
Do you see yourself as like part
of that destruction that they're,
they're putting on themselves?
- Yeah I see a part
of, I see a part of the
destruction that they put it
on themselves because I
was a part of it, too.
And I see myself being destructed, too.
But I caught myself and
I snapped out of it.
- (producer) Yeah. How
do you, I mean, when you
when you see them and they're
just getting worse and worse
do you ever like give
them advice or tell them
anything or?
- Yeah. I talk to them,
I always talk to them.
'Cause, I mean, you
have to talk to somebody
that means there's somebody
who's always something
on somebody's mind. Somebody
might need to let out.
So I speak to everybody,
I talk to everybody,
I treat everybody the same
way I want to be treated.
- (producer) Yeah. But at end of the day,
they still need what they need
- At the end of the day they
still need what they need.
- (producer) And you
have a son or daughter?
- I have a daughter.
- (producer) You have a daughter?
- Yeah
- (producer) And you still
have contact with her?
- Not really 'cause I really don't know
where they went to and everything.
Everybody just disappeared so,
I haven't seen her in a minute.
- (producer) Yeah.
Looking back at your
childhood do you think
your mom was out of
the picture very early?
Your dad was kind of out of the picture?
- Hmm
- (producer) A lot of,
it sounds like a lot of
physical abuse.
- Yeah.
- (producer) Do you think
that kind of led you
into this lifestyle?
- Yeah it played a big part in it.
- (producer) So here
you are, here you are at
38 and you're
- Out here in these streets
_ (producer) out here in the streets.
- Yeah.
Played a big part in it.
- (producer) Yeah.
What do you, what do you wish you, I mean
when you were a young
boy did you have dreams
of a different life?
- When I was young, I always
wanted to be a fireman.
I just thought that was
cool to be a fireman.
And when I got older, it
just ended up with the
wrong crowd and ended up gang banging,
selling drugs and running
around in the street.
- (producer) Were gangs
a part of your life?
- Yeah, it was, it played part of my life.
- (producer) Yeah. And gangs and drugs
kind of go together, right?
- Yeah, it's all in one package.
- (producer) Yeah.
- Yeah.
- (producer) Do you think
if you grew up in another
part of the country-
- I'd be a totally different person.
- (producer) Yeah?
A very different person.
- (producer) Yeah.
You have friends of yours, you've seen,
you know, long prison
sentences? And death?
And all that kind of stuff?
- Yeah, I have friends
around, I have friends around,
I have friends that passed,
you know, I have friends that
are not friends anymore, you know.
Out here in the street life's
always going to be like that.
- (producer) What do
you think the solution
to the problem is?
- For me I think, find
me a job or something,
or find me a lady that,
that understand me and
understand the streets.
Like, I think a lady that understand how
the streets really work
from her being out here
in these streets from
doing bad, to doing good.
I need a lady like that, so therefore she
know how to deal with me
and she know how to work
with me and understand me.
- (producer) Have you been in love before?
- Hmm?
- Yeah. Yeah. When it
don't go good, it hurts.
- (producer) Yeah, no kidding.
What can of kid were you in high school?
- I never really made it,
I went to all special ed
schools, all continuations,
all my schools had probation
officers and handcuffs.
- (producer) Oh, I see.
The first time you started
using was what age?
- About 12.
I started off smoking Primos
- (producer) Which is cocaine-
- Yeah, crack cocaine and weed.
- (producer) How do you
think all these years of
doing this, living this
lifestyle, has changed you?
- It changed me a lot
because I'm a grown man.
I'm a grown man and survive
while out here I gotta survive.
So, you know, I just try
to live one day at a time.
- (producer) Yeah. Did
you have role models
when you were a kid that-
- Nope.
- (producer) Nothing? Just-
- (Michael) Nope.
- (producer) Just the streets?
- (Michael) Yup. All My
role models taught me
how to sell drugs, steal
cars and write on walls.
- (producer) All right, Michael.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- No problem.
- (producer) Good luck with that with
wherever you go from here.
- Yep. No problem.
Thank you